mais d'abord évidemment l'actualité
politique c'est la droite qui se déchire
eric woerth rallye le président la
république
rachida dati sort la sulfateuse contre
le directeur de campagne de valérie
pécresse bref ça se fissure chez elle
hier famille ricker c'est un tacle
violent adressé par rachida dati à
patrick stefanini entre l'ancienne
candidate a l'air à paris et le
directeur de campagne de valérie
pécresse le ton ne cesse de monter
depuis plusieurs jours donc les leçons
de campagne frémit de ses gardes et donc
voilà donc moi 10 12 heures ça ne
m'intéresse pas les acteurs de la grèce
là oui il fait d'accord failli moi je
lui ai d'ailleurs dit faudrait pas trop
qu'elle nous montre une ambiance
délétère symbole des fractures à droite
et des difficultés de valérie pécresse à
rassembler son camp alors qu'un soutien
de taille se fait toujours attendre
celui de nicolas sarkozy jeudi le figaro
publié les propos très sévères de
l'ancien président au sujet de la
candidate valérie part dans tous les
sens déjà si dans une campagne tu
arrives à imprimer une ou deux idées
c'est un miracle il faut marteler en
permanence en 2007 on parlait de sarko
matin midi et soir mais là qui parle de
valérie pécresse elle est inexistante
elles seraient bien inspirés de me citer
un peu si elle veut que je la
soutiennent de quoi enfoncer un peu plus
valérie pécresse au lendemain de la
défection d'eric woerth le député
président de la commission des finances
à l'assemblée rallye emmanuel macron
pour sébastien lecornu lui-même un
transfuge des républicains ce serait
même un tournant dans la campagne
témoigne aux fonctions la capacité à
rassembler pour une raison d'ailleurs
que logique c'est que lorsqu'on fabrique
de toutes pièces un bon programme qui
n'est jamais que l'addition des
programmes de monsieur ciotti de
monsieur barnier de monsieur bertrand
enfin espèce de bouillie guga
idéologique absolument indigeste pas
fondamentalement on perd le fil avec les
électeurs au coude à coude avec marine
le pen dans les sondages valérie
pécresse doit désormais faire taire les
divisions au sein de son camp son
meeting dimanche à paris s'annonce déjà
décisif dans deux mois jour pour jour on
vote pour le premier tour de la
présidentielle pour l'instant beaucoup
de français peut-être vous avez le
sentiment que les propositions n'imprime
pas j'ai donc demandé à mes invités de
choisir un moment fort et une promesse
de campagne
bonsoir sarah b louisane bienvenus vous
accueillez vous êtes journaliste
politique au monde en charge du suivi de
la droite bruno cautrès bonsoir oui la
chercheur au cnrs et au cevipof pablo
pino vivien bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes
responsables it auriel de la revue
regards laetitia cruppe avant-soirée
littéralisme éthique à mes côtés comme
chaque mardi et chaque jeudi bon on
vient de voir cette cette journée où ces
journées difficiles pour la droite ça
belouizad votre événement va commencer
par l'événement vous avez choisi alors
il est à venir pourquoi c'est le meeting
de valérie pécresse ce dimanche et à
venir parce que c'est le meeting au
zénith son premier en fait vrai meeting
mine de rien depuis qu'elle a été
désignée le 4 décembre elle doit réunir
six mille personnes il attend de 5 à
droite qu'ils attendent ça et elle
devait faire ça au début la mutualité
souvenez vous quand a été désigné il
nous avait dit on va faire un grand truc
ça va être super on va lancer la
campagne au micro est arrivé à la pac eu
là ils veulent faire à un moment
marquant qui marque un peu le tournant
pour passer à autre chose pour essayer
de un peu de conjurer un peu ce faux
plat dans quel dans lequel elle est un
vrai faux plat bruno cautrès quand on
voit bien par ce reportage de l'an mille
ans à droite là c'est quand même
particulier entre le ralliement d'eric
woerth c'est rachida dati on en a vu
quoi on en a vu 20 secondes mais ça dure
ça dure longtemps donc oui et c'est
vraiment une séquence qui va rester
certainement de cette campagne présence
et vous dit quoi que la candidate et
l'air elles elles rament à
contre-courant la peau non on avait le
sentiment qu'on s'embête est un peu dans
cette campagne et là on voit qu on est
en train de passer à une autre vitesse
les esprits commencent à s'échauffer
donc on est vraiment maintenant dans le
coeur de la campagne c'est vrai qu'on
voit qu'à droite
l'objectif était de montrer que la
famille s'était réunie c'était ça le
message à la sortir de là à sortir de la
primaire la fin et on a eu cette photo
de famille des amis voilà et chacun
avait mis beaucoup du sien au fond
valérie pécresse est revenu chez les
républicains donc voilà et puis voilà on
voit que dans la famille quand même
beaucoup de tension et ça traduit
effectivement que elle a quand même du
mal à faire ressortir ses principales
propositions est effectivement un enjeu
considérable pour elle sur le prochain
sur le prochain meeting et quand
l'ancien président république d'ici
c'est bien les propos qu'il a tenus on
parlait de moi matin midi et soir c'est
vrai que d'une certaine manière là c'est
plutôt exe moore qui a pris cette place
dans ces deux cas
[Musique]
d'eric zemmour dans cette campagne et ça
devient très difficile pour tous les
autres candidats pas seulement la
candidate des républicains ont paradé
autres candidats tout à l'heure à gauche
en particulier on voit qu'il ya beaucoup
de difficultés à trouver sa place à
exister puis un phénomène qui touche
tout l'espace public cette espèce de
campagne politique ou campagne
permanente au fond il devient très
difficile de marquer la différence et
dire là on est vraiment maintenant dans
une campagne j'ai mes propositions à
faire connaître puisque l'espace public
est saturé en permanence de propositions
de contre proposition de débat dans tous
les sens pablo pino vivien camp quand on
lit ces propos rapportés effectivement
de nicolas sarkozy
c'est dans le figaro elle ferait bien de
me citer c'est un peu j'ai pas quelques
âmes employés puéril et gothique
gothique mais ça dit quand même parce
qu'au delà de ça il ya quand même aussi
une question de d'isolement de stratégie
de soutien attendu par valérie pécresse
en fait vous l'avez un bruno cautrès là
un peu dit le valérie pécresse était la
promesse en fait de réunir la famille
ccsa au sortir de la primaire enfin du
congrès de dlr afin qu'il apporte est
politiquement le seul problème c'est
qu'en fait la politique c'est pas qu'une
course de petits chevaux c'est pas que
qu'il a rallié qui autour de qui vous
allez vous entourer est ce que vous
allez plutôt vous entourer de nicolas
sarkozy ou de telle autre cador de la
droite et on est en train de résumer la
peña politique à ça alors que le
problème et c'est pas qu'un problème de
propositions si moi je suis assez
d'accord avec ce que disait le ministre
le corps nu tout à l'heure à votre micro
il disait voilà c'est une suite de
propositions un peu comme samuel mise
pêle mêle il faut un projet et le prêt
du colbras et le problème c'est que la
colonne vertébrale de valérie pécresse
avait pas très identifiable allez allez
un peu genre coincé entre à la fois la
radicalité sur les questions de sécurité
d'immigration de on va dire le pôle
racistes d'extrême droite qui comprend
eric zemmour et marine le pen et d'un
autre côté en gros le pôle européiste et
libérale d'emmanuel macron et elle c'est
pour moi je n'arrive pas alors que je
l'écoutais 1 sans arrêt je vois les
propositions qu'elle fait je n'arrive
pas à identifier
en fait qu'elle est là quelle pourrait
être la singularité du projet qu'elle
fait pour la france pour les dix
prochaines années à venir sarah
belouizad vous suivez la droite est ce
que la droite n'a pas assez travaillé on
a déjà plusieurs fois sur ce plateau ça
de la gauche un peu moins de la droite
alors ce qui est intéressant ce que
c'est eric woerth dont on parlait tout à
l'heure qui rallie emmanuel macron c'est
ce qu'il dit c'est le fond de son propos
et je suis pas sûr que la droite n'est
pas assez travaillé je suis pas sûr que
ce soit c'est un problème je pense que
pablo a raison parce que le problème des
pécresse c'est qu'on ne l'identifient
pas en fait de quoi décret c' est elle
le nom qu'est ce que qu'est ce qu'elle
incarne sarko on savait il y avait
évidemment
le message le travailler plus pour
gagner plus et puis y avait cette
énergie en fait qu il avait l aile et
c'est une femme brillante qui a des
idées qui en a plein qui est plutôt
raisonnable
kiki et de centre-droit en effet mais
qui n'arrivent pas à imprimer une marque
c'est pour ça que le 13 février il va
falloir que qu'elle donne une vision en
fait c'est quoi la france voulue par
valérie pécresse chose que c'est un
mauvais procès d'intention
parce que finalement si elle n'a prime
passé parce que son projet politique est
très proche de celui d'emmanuel mâcon
c'est tout c'est pas la personnalité de
la grèce qui pose problème peut-être
qu'elle va fendre l'armure puisque
maintenant tous les journalistes en
semant à la bouche et les communicants
et c'est vraiment le l'exposition à kg
il faut se différencier par la
personnalité forcément et une campagne
présidentielle c'est quand même beaucoup
ça thomas fin autres événements mais
j'espère que je sais bien qu'on est dans
une société ultra connectés complètement
saturée d'imagés et de coups médiatiques
mais enfin j'espère que une personnalité
ne peut pas justement combler un manque
un déficit de programmes page et j'ose
le croire et là problème de bail
précaire pécresse c'est qu'elle ne se
démarque pas assez des manuels macro
elle se démarque quand même de l'extrême
droite parce qu'elle n'arrête pas à elle
de dire quelle est celle qui tient le
cordon sanitaire justement qui aura
disparu avec certains de son parti elle
c'est très clair c'est comme edouard
philippe à dire que leurs propos sont
très clairs sur cette ligne rouge mais
c'est parce que son programme il est
trop proche assure jay manuel may cry
allait lancer un tout petit peu la vie
parce que hier 1 et les médias on a
plein événements et opposition à l'essai
de se différencier qui est la question
des déficits publics les réductions
d'emplois dans la fonction publique sur
lesquels emmanuel macron avait dit
finalement que je qu'il en fera pas et
donc elle a essayé de parler à ce qui
parle au plan économique au coeur de la
droite c'est à dire moins d'impôts moins
de dépenses publiques moins de
fonctionnaires et ce triptyque reste
important aux yeux des électeurs de
droite donc après et elle a un bilan
l'occident sur ce problème c'est que
année un vote c'est quelque chose
d'assez irrational ans et on ne peut pas
miser sur la rationalité des agents donc
c'est vrai que quand même que
l'incarnation est quelque chose de
charnel quand même dans le rapport des
français en tout cas c'est bien parce
que je suis d'accord
j'essaie de me dire que on va se
rattraper et se raccrocher à la raison
avons choisi un autre événement fort une
autre une autre date c'est celle que
vous avez choisi bruno cautrès et le 8
décembre qu'est ce qui se passe ce jour
là c'est le jour où la candidate
socialiste
décide finalement de faire demi tour
elle est pour moitié sa protégée pour
poitiers oui même après oui pour la
rochelle et demi tour et là il ya un
événement de campagne important qui va
avoir des conséquences pour la suite
elle se déclare en faveur au fond d'une
primaire est elle à une interview le
soir même on la voit là une interview
elle dit bah finalement la seule manière
d'en sortir pour la situation confuse
qui est à gauche c'est de revenir sur la
question de la de la primaire mais une
authentique primaire pas seulement la
primaire compte des écologistes entre
eux pas seulement la primaire qu'on
pourrait jouer un comité sera donc une
véritable primaire et où on voit qu'elle
va un peu utilisé là l'idée de la
primaire populaire on sait pas très bien
si c'est de la primaire populaire le
coup est parti dont elle pas si c'est
une autre forme de primaires on voit que
ça va avoir des conséquences qui sont
assez importantes au fond ça introduit
une période très grande confusion à
gauche sur qui va qui n'y va pas quel
est le sens de cette primaire qui se
retiraient derrière qui lui ont parlé
des propositions puis finalement elle
passe à la trappe
puisqu'on ne parle plus que d'eux la
question ont-ils participé à la primaire
la situation à gauche n'est toujours pas
remise de cette situation même s'il ya
une candidate christiane taubira qui a
gagné finalement la primaire dit
populaire et puis j'ai trouvé que
c'était intéressant parce que j'ai
trouvé que c'était tellement
métaphorique d'une campagne qui a du mal
à trouver sa direction pas seulement
pour les candidats de la gauche pour
d'autres candidats on va dans un sens on
va dans l'eau dans l'autre c'est j'ai
trouvé ça incroyablement le métaphorique
de cette campagne et puis en plus c'est
le justifie d'abord dans les premières
heures par là une question de gestion de
la crise sanitaire on comprend qu'en
fait c'est pour aller sur le plateau du
journal de tf1 pablo pino via quand on a
on a beaucoup puisque tourner sur la
gauche on a beaucoup parlé cette semaine
de tractations entre les équipes de de
yannick jadot et de christiane taubira
est ce que évidemment vous avez pas une
boule de cristal mais est ce qu'une
fusion est encore possible mais on n'a
pas les tractations encore une fois
comme si c'était des équipes de foot et
que c'était un mercato et qu'il fallait
savoir dar kifa et se rangent etc moi je
pense que ce qui est intéressant dans ce
qu en train de se passer avec voilà ces
discussions qui peuvent avoir lieu entre
les équipes de jadot et les équipes de
taubira c'est qu'en fait tu es en train
de se reconstituer ou plutôt il faudrait
qu'il se reconstitue au nom de la fin
d'une meilleure compréhension de ce que
c'est que à la fois genre le paysage
démocratique aujourd'hui et de la gauche
le pôle social démocrate et aujourd'hui
il ya un pôle social démocrate qui qui
existent mais presque 2 par malgré lui
c'est il est incarné par à la fois
yannick jadot à la fois anne hidalgo est
à la fois christiane taubira dont il ya
quand même trois personnalités qui
incarnent cet art que la avec puisqu'on
parle de programme dense et ma part dans
un peu d'intérêt des nuances mais pas de
différence majeure enfin je veux dire
c'est absolument ridicule on sait très
bien que jean les raisons pour
lesquelles aujourd'hui il ya trois
écuries dans la social démocratie c'est
uniquement parce que derrière il ya des
des législatives parce que c'était ça le
vrai ne le vrai enjeu de la réunion
d'arrière boutique entre les équipes de
jade octobre ira c'était en fait
derrière taubira c'était surtout le p r
gère le parti radical de gauche c'était
de décider comment ils allaient se
répartir les circonscriptions aux
législatives
et c'est ça qui est un peu dramatique
c'est ça qui est en train de tuer la
campagne présidentielle à gauche c'est
qu'ils sont déjà en train de penser
comment est-ce qu'on va le peu de chose
qui va rester le peu de sièges de
députés de gauche et des écologistes qui
va qui va rester en 2022 comment va se
répartir comment va se répartir ce ce
bout de chagrin et etc etc en train de
tuer le un débat qui pourrait être
intéressant enfin entre 3 pôles un pôle
communiste un pôle social démocrate
écologiste et impôts le impôts
l'insoumis dont je serai pas tellement
comment le définir en un seul mot mais
voilà ça pourrait être intéressant ce
débat là et il n'a pas lieu parce qu'on
pense toujours que il va pouvoir se
résoudre à la première populaire avait
pensé qu'un outil allez pouvoir enfin
juste une plateforme numérique allait
pouvoir résoudre tous les problèmes de
la gauche je pense qu'il faut un peu
plus d'huile de coude un peu plus
d'intelligence collective que juste une
plateforme numérique alors on reste sur
justement cette social-démocratie
laetitia colle pas avec alors on a fait
deux événements là on va passer à une
proposition phare elle vient de yannick
jadot 7 sont ni sf climatique on les
écoute on établit nagui et c'est parce
que les plus riches doivent contribuer à
l'hôpital à l'école aux routes et à
l'ensemble de la transition il devient
climatique parce que les patrimoines
financiers aujourd'hui sont la
principale raison pour laquelle les plus
riches et met cinq fois plus de co2 que
les français en moyenne alors mais
s'invite en plus de co2 mais trouve que
vous aurez un malus si votre patrimoine
financier par exemple participent au
projet de total en afrique ou en dans
l'arctique ou totale de continuer à
explorer exploitée des énergies fossiles
les ti siècle il n'est pas seul sur ce
terrain le candidat européen ce qui est
intéressant parce que cette idée a dit
sf climatique elle est aussi prise par
anne hidalgo défendu par anne hidalgo et
jean luc mélenchon mais pas dans les
termes vraiment exact de sf climatique
jean luc mélenchon il rétablit sf il met
un volet climatique et le rétablit et le
renforce a également cette cet impôt est
en fait c'est greenpeace qui avait
proposé cette cette mesure aussi la
convention citoyenne pour le climat
qu'on a tous oublié mais rappelez-vous
des citoyens avaient été tirés au sort
pour apporter des mesures pour sauver la
planète mais c'était dans leur mesure et
tout était parti de la contestation des
gilet jaune ça c'est intéressant parce
que l'ancrage il est dans l'actualité
sociale directe que la france a vécu ce
déchirement donc qui a finit finalement
par se tuer ou être tué dans l'oeuf mais
qui a vraiment menacé de très près le
pouvoir le pouvoir l'élysée emmanuel
macron est en fait cette contestation de
la taxe carbone finalement a révélé
qu'il fallait absolument un consensus
pour tous qui étaient politiques
publiques de protection de
l'environnement ça semble très évident
comme ça thomas mais ce n'est pas si
évident que cela et finalement yannick
jadot se positionne très clairement sur
un impôt qui est symbolique à gauche
très fort un marqueur très fort et aussi
avec la protection
jagger c'est un cumul de marqueurs et à
mon avis pour l'électorat de gauche
c'est assez efficace pablo c'est
d'autant plus efficace que il ya quelque
chose qui n'est pas résolu à gauche on a
cru un moment qu'il a et qu'il avait été
résolu par un slogan qui était fin du
monde fin du mois même combat et en fait
ce slogan est sorti dans l'est notamment
dans les marches pour une clients et on
s'est dit c'est bon on a résolu la
question de la hiérarchie en fait de la
question sociale et de la question et de
l'urgence écologique alors qu'en fait
c'est pas du tout le cas quelqu'un qui
le 15 du mois à son frigidaire vide et
ne sait pas comment il va le remplir
pour les quinze derniers jours du mois
eh ben il peut pas réfléchir à la
question à la question écologique par en
tout cas c'est très compliqué et
aujourd'hui vous avez pas mal d fracture
qui divise la gauche qui se font sur la
base de cette hiérarchie en fait fabien
roussel il dit bah non moi je suis
désolé mais on peut pas les catégories
populaires et fabien roussel on voit il
est plutôt en dynamique aujourd'hui le
candidat du parti communiste il dit on
peut pas genre
inféodé la question écologique à paf
plutôt rares furent des toutes les
questions à la question écologique il
faut d'abord penser la question sociale
et ensuite on raisonne en résolvera je
le fais un peu car il a également mais
on réservera la question écolo et l'a
finalement avec cette sf climatique qui
portait effectivement comme vous le
dites par anne hidalgo et yannick jadot
et et
changement du mélenchon il le résolve un
peu c'est à dire qu'il dit d'abord
regarder non on va mettre à profit des
riches et les catégories populaires vous
n'allez pas être touché france est par
essence le sfc après quatre épreuves
colère c'est une façon c'est une façon
de résoudre mais en vérité je pense que
la question elle est beaucoup plus
profond que ça bruno cautrès ya quand
même moi quelque chose qui me frappe
même si je suis assez d'accord avec vous
lorsque vous décrivez sa joie sur la
consommation de lait terre que la
consommation de lait bio est là elle a
cité au profit du lait produit
localement du circuit court parce que il
ya un moment où il le les circuits
courts il est moins cher et donc on fait
ce choix plutôt que d'aller vers un live
view mais mais quand même il ya une
partie de français de l'opinion
française notamment chez les jeunes qui
votent avec leur carte bancaire de
et sonic font des choix pour la
transition écologique qui sont passés
jadot aujourd'hui en tout cas pas dans
l'est dans les sondages comme lui une
série ce paradoxe comme ça dans cette
élection effectivement la préoccupation
pour le climat est dans le top 5 on va
dire des préoccupations des français
qu'ils décrivent au moment de voter en
disant au moment de voter voilà l'ordre
des préoccupations que j'ai il ya le
pouvoir d'achat blessure mais la
question aussi climatiques
environnementales au sens large du
sancerre je t'aime et le candidat qui
porte cette question qui devrait de ce
fait là être beaucoup plus haut non
seulement ils plafonnent mais il
régresse même depuis qu'il a gagné la la
primaire est un autre paradoxe qui est
que les attentes de justice sociale sont
très forte dans le pays également des
candidats de la gauche qui incarne
normalement la justice sociale n'arrive
pas donc une série de comme ça de
paradoxe sans doute parce qu'ils ont
beaucoup de mal les uns et les autres à
expliquer comment tout ceci s'articule à
d'autres volets serre c'est bien d'avoir
sans doute un isf climatique pour
dégager des moyens et préserver la
planète bien évidemment mais comment
tout ça s'inscrit dans un ensemble de
mesures économiques un peu plus un peu
plus la jsk décohérence des incohérences
et sur ces différentes mesures est ce
que les différents candidats de la
gauche disent exactement la même chose
si on les mettait de même atteint autour
de la table du gouvernement est ce
qu'ils ont la capacité à gouverner sur
ces questions sans s'engueuler et donc
voilà il ya des cas il ya des cas il ya
d'expliquer un peu aussi c'est comment
quand on voit comment allait croiser sur
son chemin en allemagne voilà bon bref
mais c'est pas du tout la même culture
politique mais en fait c'est très
intéressant ce que vous dites parce
qu'il ya une question de crédibilité en
fait c'est ça c'est que les gens se
disent si l'udps ça quoi ça sert
d'écouter ce qu'il dit ou ce la mesure
la plus intéressante qui soit si le type
qui n'apportaient pas un crédit pour
gouverner
alors on reste sur ce sur le camp
écologiste pablo
pile bien parce que vous avez choisi
vous comme comme date comme moment fort
la primaire écolo pour moi alors c'est
la primaire écolo je le rappelle avait
eu lieu les deux dernières semaines du
mois de septembre dernier est en fait je
voulais parler de ça parce que c'était
le dernier moment où moi moi je fais
beaucoup de plateaux télé on commente
comme vous tous autour de cette table on
commande souvent l'actualité politique
et ses derniers moments en fait on n'a
pas parlé d' eric zemmour et après à
partir du mois d'octobre zemmour n'est
pas rentrer en campagne mais des
facteurs en fait il était rentré en
campagne on a commencé il a commencé à
être sondés et c est dans la primaire
écologiste j'ai trouvé ça c'était un
moment où en fait on avait ou non se
poser d'autres questions dans le débat
public avec était apporté d'autres types
de propositions et en plus de ça vous
aviez cinq candidats qui avaient des
propositions pour la france qui était à
la fois radicalement différente qui ont
ils ont participé à des débats qui
étaient de très haute tenue j'ai trouvé
intellectuelle dire qu'il y avait
vraiment des débats entre delphine batho
qui était plutôt sur les questions de
décroissance est assez ferme sur les
questions régaliennes vous aviez yannick
jadot qui voulait rassembler tout le
monde
sandrine rousseau qui était plutôt dans
une dans une radicalité
intersectionnelle qui était qui était
très intéressante et eric vial qui
essayaient de rassembler un arc
humaniste fait des différentes
propositions des différentes
associations et j'avais trouvé que ça
avait une grande tenue et dans une
certaine mesure j'avais trouvé un peu
dans le même genre là le congrès elle
est enfin seb se dope primaire ddl elle
aussi avait été un moment assez comme on
dit alors là pour localiser les
thématiques chères à eric zemmour elle
était au coeur elle était à la fois au
coeur des débats est à la fois il y
avait des tentatives en fait de se
démarquer par moments que j'ai trouvée
est en tout cas vous aviez quatre
propositions pour la france tété ou cinq
visites et combien
les cinq propositions pour la france qui
était identifiable et identifiés et
c'est ce qui manque je trouve
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui vous avez je
sais plus combien de candidats à
l'élection présidentielle
et comme on le disait tout à l'heure sur
var libre et que si on n'arrive pas à
identifier ce qu'elle forte dans les
rues cada le portait mieux dans la
primaire que après une fois qu'elle est
ce qu'elle est excellente à la
télévision elle arrive à se montrer à se
glisser dans le costume présidentiel
justement parce qu'en plus c'est quand
même une mécanique intellectuelle qui
est impressionnante elle a des idées et
elle sait les exprimer après pendant le
congrès ait l'air c'est vrai que
énormément de temps a quand même été
consacrée aux questions régaliennes
parce que enfin de quoi questions
sécuritaires pardon pas que reaganienne
parce que il s'est adressé aux militants
et l'air est pas toute la france alors
pardon on va parler d'eric zemmour dans
ce débat peut-on faire autrement puisque
c'est l'une des propositions vous avez
choisi bruno cautrès on écoute eric
zemmour parler à la france rurale
la plus forte jamais proposé aux
français qui vivent enfin une mesure
pour les faits pour nos enfants une
mesure pour la jeunesse une mesure pour
la natalité une mesure pour l'avenir une
mesure pour le retour
pour la survie
2020 pour chaque nouvel enfant né dans
une famille de la france rurale
de naissance de
[Musique]
10000 euros pour chaque famille de la
france rurale bruno cautrès pourquoi ce
choix parce que c'est vraiment ce qu'on
appelle une proposition marquantes
facile à identifier à retenir pour les
pour les électeurs je ne me prononce pas
sur le fond de la mesure mais uniquement
vraiment sur les faits qu'elle fait sur
ce qu'ils écoutent eric zemmour et qui
adhèrent à son discours s'est facilement
imprimable on peut facilement se saisir
de cette proposition et surtout la
manière dont ils la présentent on voit
qu'elle synthétise à elle seule beaucoup
d'éléments d'eric zemmour de son
programme on parle de natalité donc
indirectement on parle évidemment de la
question qui obsède eric zemmour à
celles du remplacement on parle aussi de
ruralité donc ça évoque évidemment tout
de suite la france d'avant on va parler
aussi d'une mesure qui s'adresse aux
familles est donc là aussi on insiste
sur un marqueur et donc c'est une
proposition qui à la fois très simple à
mémoriser et qu'en même temps va comme
essais mais plein de signaux qui sont en
direction de l'électorat cible d'eric
zemmour après si on rentre un peu dans
le détail comment on la met en place
comme on est folle une famille rurale
combien sac se prononçait pas sur
l'homme et sur le légèrement aussi les
ans un débat je sais pas sur un débat
sur le fond c'est typiquement le genre
de proposition qui ne peut que conduire
vers beaucoup de difficultés beaucoup
d'ennuis si on essaie de les mettre en
oeuvre
laetitia veut
vous avez choisi ressasser la date c'est
l'événement phare que vous avez choisi
et il concerne eric zemmour c'est le
clip de son entrée en campagne c'est ça
le 30 novembre mais ça rejoint
exactement ce que vous venez de dire
bruno parce que vous n'avez pas prononcé
ce mot populiste parce que c'est une
mesure populiste finalement les 10000
euros pour chaque enfant né dans une
famille à la campagne on entend
peut-être famille patrie aussi mais bien
sûr qu'en fait cette vidéo elle est
absolument marquantes je pense que c'est
le fait de campagne jusqu'à maintenant
on n'a pas encore l'entrée en campagne
d'emmanuel macron mais jusqu'à
maintenant pourquoi parce que ça reste
un ovni un objet politique non identifié
or elle était prévisible de bout en bout
pourquoi parce qu'il propose dans la
lignée des populistes trump zenasci mais
aussi boris johnson et bolton araud il
propose une candidature transgressive
populiste hors système des tickets le
répète tout le temps finalement et on a
déjà cette galaxie populiste qui
installés en dehors de nos frontières
depuis des années avec les mêmes
mécanismes
le thème de votre livre la tentation du
clown exactement donc effectivement
c'est un sujet qui me passionne mais
vraiment quand on regarde en dehors de
chez nous tout a déjà été fait et il
n'était impossible d'avoir un autre
espace que celui des réseaux sociaux et
du numérique pour lancer sa campagne si
vous voulez s'était absolument cohérent
avec la candidature qu'il propose et
pourquoi c'est efficace parce que comme
on a l'impression que tout est nouveau
soudainement et qu'il arrive et qu'il a
fait une entrée fracassante dans la
campagne parce que il propose quelque
chose que personne n'avait jamais fait
avant on s'arrête on est un peu
stupéfaits et on regarde les audiences
2,6 millions en trois jours je n'ai pas
fait encore le comte là c'est un peu
plus difficile de la trouver cette vidéo
parce que youtube après av
un multi souci sur le droit à l'image
disent non au début parce qu'après après
y'a aucun droit donc quand vous êtes
d'humeur aussi si c'est difficile il
faut montrer un pas que ça s'ébruite
aujourd'hui 2,6 millions le soir même il
va sur le plateau du jt de tf1 7 2
millions c'est à dire qu'on peut
imaginer qu'il a touché quasiment 10
millions en très peu de temps bien sûr
qu'il avait eue notoriété acquise
auparavant comme donald trump par la
télévision mais là cette entrée là elles
marquent définitivement la campagne de
2011 mais sarah b loin de moi ce qui me
frappe c'est quand on regarde les
intentions de vote au second tour eric
zemmour il est systématiquement très
très loin il ya autour de 35% et malgré
tout ils gardent un socle qui est solide
au premier tour comment vous l'analysez
ça alors c'est vrai que du coup ils ne
bénéficient pas de ce qu'on appelle le
vote utile oui on pourrait imaginer que
les gens disent beaucoup y sert à rien
de continuer de dire je votais zemmour
au premier tour parce que de toute façon
ils perdent encore encore tout à fait
parce que si si la dynamique parce que
là on voit un petit frémissement quand
ils augmentent 1 et monte un peu dans
les sondages si la dynamique continue
peut-être qu'il pourrait bénéficier d'un
vote utile est peut-être que le ratio
serait appelé exactement le même après
il ya quand même aussi des gens qui se
disent que hand en le soutenant il en
pose ces thèmes à lui dans le débat ce
qui s'est passé notamment à droite parce
que finalement commis ils sont mal à
l'aise avec lui parce qu'ils ont
énormément de militants et des lecteurs
ils le savent qu'ils sont intéressés par
ce qu'il dit forcément il parle de il
parle un peu comme lui incertain
certains égards donc ça veut dire quand
même que les il parle elle entre en
résonance avec certains français qui se
disent quoi qu'il arrive j'y vais parce
que comme ça on va parler d'eux des
sujets qui m'intéressent oui et puis je
sais pas si vous vous est d'accord avec
pas moins de 4 s mais j'ai le sentiment
que ce sont presque sont alors il
s'élargit mais son cercle de fidèles
et au succès de ses livres depuis des
années il ya sans doute aussi de ça on
peut pas expliquer une dynamique aussi
fulgurante que celle qu'il a eue pendant
pendant l'automne s'il n'y a pas à faire
défection un terreau avant effectivement
la notoriété qu'il avait acquise sur des
thèmes sur lesquels il est cohérent
depuis des années c'est vrai que
beaucoup de français considèrent que les
hommes et les femmes politiques
zig zag au gré des élections et leurs
intérêts et lui c'est vrai que de ce
point de vue là il l'a est arrivé à
faire passer là à l'image à la fois de
quelqu'un qui est uniquement dans la
conviction dans la cohérence et il ne
cesse de marteler je ne suis pas un
homme politique je ne suis pas un
politicien je ne fais pas partie du club
et c'est pour ça qu'il ne m'aime pas et
donc c'est vrai que de ce point de vue
là il a utilisé des ressorts qui étaient
des ressorts sans aucun doute d'une très
grande efficacité aux yeux d'une opinion
publique ou d'un segment de pions public
qui regarde la vie politique comme un
jeu qui ne leur appartient pas et là ils
ont trouvé quelqu'un qui leur dit bah on
va jouer à un autre jeu est ce que
j'allais dire parce que plus que
effectivement un électorat potentiel
fidèles un coeur de cible il peut aussi
incarner le vote de des gens qui sont en
colère le vote contestataire on en a
marre d'un système prétendument
élitiste qui nous écarter qui ne
reconnaît pas notre utilité sociale et
donc on va aller voter contre et donc
eric zemmour il peut incarner ce vote là
pas uniquement la france
passée la nostalgie un peu rance etc oui
bien sûr que c'est une partie de son
électorat mais pas que c'est pour ça que
sa marge de progression il faut pas et
on savait 1 depuis septembre à chaque
fois vous poser la question alors est-ce
que ça va s'arrêter et cetera mois
depuis franchement depuis cet été je dis
non ça ne va pas s'arrêter et cette
bulle ne s'est pas arrêté pour le moment
c'est un idéologue en campagne depuis le
début vous avez dit oui j'ai depuis le
début il dit je ne suis pas un homme
politique comme les autres mais parce
qu'il est un idéologue et il mène une
bataille culturelle et force est de
constater qu'il est en train de la
gagner on utilisait tout à l'heure mais
c'est lui en fait qui marquent le tempo
delà de la campagne c'est lui qui impose
ses thèmes et même sur des thèmes où on
l'attend pas sur les questions de
pouvoir d'achat sur la question du
permis à points en fait on fait réagir
les autres candidats de façon
systématique ou quasi sur les
propositions dirais que oui mais quand
on écoute les sondeurs il ya un taux de
détestation d'eric zemmour qui est le
plus élevé de tous les candidats donc
c'est quand même un lourd handicap oui
non mais c'est un long retour pour une
dynamique de campagne il perce pas
exactement de crever ce plafond d'heures
la modification moi je depuis le départ
je ne pense pas que le but d'eric
zemmour soit véritablement d'être
président de la république alors
peut-être qu'au bout d'un moment il est
un peu grisé aussi par des sondages qui
sont plutôt bons et comme vous l'avez
dit un socle qui est en train de se
constituer évidemment c'est un peu comme
donald trump un donald trump lorsqu'il a
commencé lorsqu'il s'est lancé dans la
course présidentielle il le dit lui même
avait failli l'a dit lui même a
posteriori il ne pensait pas gagner la
course présidentielle il pensait juste
voilà faire parler de lui à faire parler
ses idées etc - il a fini par gagner la
présidentielle mais pas sur la base
passe de hilla est pas comme stratégie
dès le départ de gagner en présentiel et
eric zemmour non plus alors
effectivement c'est grisant en fait au
bout d'un moment d'être candidat
présentiel et d'alice en arrière et
l'érosion à autre chose c'est qu'on a vu
en 2010 est une france quand même
diviser quasiment 4 donc avec une france
finalement aussi fracturé il faut pas ça
sert à rien d'avoir plein de gens qui
vous aiment il suffit d'avoir un bon
nombre de personnes qui vous aiment
suffisamment c'est là qu'ils ont ils dit
plusieurs fois la qualification au
second tour elle se joue beaucoup à la
une qualif à l'état
aujourd'hui bien ce stade parce que ça
se trouve ça va bouger je le rappelle on
dit quasiment à chaque fois et encore
une marge d'erreur est très importante
et beaucoup de français qui n'ont pas
fait leur choix donc attention aux
sondages en termine avec deux
propositions autour du pouvoir d'achat
d'abord celle de jean luc mélenchon on
est le 2 novembre sur rtl mesures à
destination des jeunes - la solution
c'est 1000 63 euros pour tous ceux qui
sont en fac mais qui sont autonomes de
leurs parents s'il vous plaît vous
verrez quand même pas bon faut pas
exagérer non plus donc ceux qui sont au
nombre de leurs parents et ça je le vois
tout de suite parce que si les parents
déclarent sur leurs formulaires d'impôts
ou à l'eau il n'y a pas de 1063 euros
pour eux mais pour les autres oui et
puis pour les lycéens professionnels
parce que jade jure qu'on comprenne que
l'apprentissage vie n'est pas une
solution nas pablo pino vivien vous avez
choisi s'était extrait pour parler de la
jeunesse et des programmes en la matière
c'est fait oui parce que je trouve que
les politiques en destination de la
jeunesse c'est vraiment à un des parents
pauvres de la politique en général de
nos politiques publiques et ce depuis
très longtemps parce que ce n'est pas
exactement mais sûrement mais pourtant
ils vont voter mais exactement mais
en plus on entend souvent les candidats
à l'élection présidentielle ou même les
députés et ses dix notre priorité c'est
la jeunesse c'est ce qu'avait dit
françois hollande sait pas si ce que dit
c'est ce qu'avait dit aussi emmanuel
macron pour autant quand on regarde ce
qu'ils ont fait en fait à destination
des jeunes n'y a absolument rien alors
qu'il ya des supers exemple est alors
jean-luc mélenchon ne dit pas dans cet
extrait mais dans les pays du nord ils
ont ces allocations c'est revenu
universel pour les jeunes alors ils ont
des mondes différents qui sont à
destination des jeunes précisément pour
essayer qu'il devienne autonome et ne
pas les considérer on a un problème en
france c'est qu'on considère que les
jeunes c'est à dire en gros les 18 25
ans ne sont pas des individus autonome
mais qu'ils sont encore les enfants de
leurs parents et donc mais d'ailleurs
j'en ai plein jour il fait cette erreur
là bas ce qui dit il ne dit non non il
faut pas que ce soit universel ce sera
pas mille 63 euros pour tout le monde
les plus riches eux ils n'auront pas
leur acmil 63 euros mais qu'est ce qui
fait en disant ça il dit mais ça veut
dire que si vous avez 23 ans et que vos
parents sont riches il faut vous serez
toujours inféodés à vos parents vous
serez toujours sous leur coulpe et ça
c'est un énorme problème alors que dans
les pays du nord au danemark notamment
eh bien ils ont un revenu je crois
qu'elle est de l'ordre de 700 euros +
après dz pour le logement qui sont
universels mais pour assurer que leur
entrée dans la vie active dans la vie
adulte se fasse de façon indépendante et
autonome parce que le rsa il est à
combien
il ya le rsa jeunes c'est un énorme
enjeu pour l'instant il n'existe pas il
n'y a pas de rsa entre 18 et 25 ans
avant dix ans la garantie jeunes via la
gare des jeunes qui ont
fait un tout petit focus parce que ton
fils sur l'image jean luc mélenchon
bruno cautrès elle est quand même moins
toujours plombé par ses hurlements lors
de la perquisition au siège de l efi
c'était octobre 2018 c'est sûr que ça
n'a pas fait du bien à l'image de jean
luc mélenchon ça c'est une image qui
s'imprime longue
d'autant qu'il a été ensuite condamné en
justice pour avoir un peu me restait
voilà quelqu'un qui était officier de
police judiciaire je crois voilà donc ça
n'a pas fait du bien l'image de jean luc
mélenchon mais en même temps pour une
personnalité comme jean luc mélenchon au
fond ce sont des personnalités
politiques qui utilisent aussi leurs
sorts celle insoumis et jean luc
mélenchon c'est la france insoumise donc
si on est un insoumis face à la dureté
du monde dans lequel non vie on peut
peut-être aussi avoir une communication
qu'elle même était en accord avec ça
c'est à dire il montre ce jour là qu'il
est emporté par sa passion sans doute
mais aussi qu'ils s'insurgent qu'il est
véritablement l'insoumis ce jour là donc
ça a pu aussi jouer en renforçant la
l'image de janvier une chose en
socialiste dans son fan club dans son
fan-club pouvoir réaliser la même percée
qu'en 2010 est pour l'instant en tout
cas mais il reste deux mois jour pour
jour c'est mal parti mais il reste deux
mois je le rappelle est beaucoup de
français n'ont pas fait leur choix je le
rappelle allait il nous reste un dernier
choix et on aura tenu la promesse et
n'aura vu deux par pape a invité valérie
pécresse une proposition qui date du 30
janvier dernier alors il ya une valse
hésitation autour de cette proposition
on écoute quel novice joie cet
engagement d'augmenter de 10% les
salaires nets il est très fort parce que
je veux que les revenus du travail paye
plus que les revenus cassis ti ne soit
remis en cause et cet engagement il sera
tenu et personne ne me fera renoncer
alors comment on fait 3 % de baisse des
cotisations retraite dès l'été sur le
salaire brut 3 % de salaire net en plus
pour les salariés et puis j'organise une
conférence des salaires avec l'ensemble
des partenaires sociaux et nous allons
discuter de la politique salariale que
les entreprises veulent mettre en oeuvre
je veux les convaincre de prendre elles
aussi leur part à cette augmentation de
salaire je veux faire ma vie je suis
quand même cette campagne de près et je
suis content paumé sur cette mesure
j'arrive plus à savoir ce qu'ils disent
qu'il ya derrière mais c'est normal
parce qu'en fait cette mesure est
quasiment pas dogmatique de ce que c'est
que le
la puissance politique où le pouvoir
politique c'est à dire qu'elle nous
propose quelque chose qui a du sens dans
un contexte d'inflation plus élevé que
on a connu ces dernières années post
gilet jaune baisse du chômage donc a
priori on devrait dire les salaires
devraient naturellement augmenter sauf
qu'au départ elle propose 10%
d'augmentation
dont elle estime que ça devrait être
donc je vous fais pas le détail mais
c'est à coup de baisse de jusqu'à deux
fois le smic voilà jusqu'à 2,2 smic et
l'idée au départ c'était que 2/3 c'était
l'état qui prenait en charge entière les
entreprises est là le medef a bien les
entreprises ont dit ban ont allumé un
warning
voilà exactement du coup elle a revu sa
mesure qui une fois modifié en fait
n'arrivez pas du tout à 10%
d'augmentation de salaires l arrivée
certes à 3% ce qui est déjà on peut
considérer pas mal mais ensuite elle dit
elle le dit là d'ailleurs je fais une
conférence
salariale fin c'est dire qu'on discute
avec les entreprises banques soient qui
a rien de coercitif donc on est là c'est
quoi la limite c'est quoi le pouvoir
politique en fait c'est à dire que est
ce que est ce qu'un trouve en politique
tout augmenter les salaires c'est alors
que ce sera le cas de notre second débat
tout à l'heure où ce qu'on est vraiment
faire 40 minutes sur les backs des bas
salaires mais ça m'offre une une
transition toute trouvée vouliez dire un
mot là-dessus dans la quête récente
qu'on a à publier le cevipof dormait de
confiance politique on a posé la
question france est ce que vous trouvez
que l'économie actuelle profite trop
patron ou au détriment des salariés 73 %
d'accord sur cette proposition donc les
français quand ils écoutent ça on va
réunir une conférence on va négocier
avec les patrons ils ont beaucoup de
doutes on va dire bon merci beaucoup
merci à tous les trois politiciens vont
rester à mes côtés d'avoir participé à
ce débat c'était passionnant on espère
avoir répondu à votre demande un peu
plus de de contenu et d'information sur
les programmes des candidats